hello and welcome to this video plane
she Lucy - Lucy whatever I do it's wrong
pronunciation wise okay cutter French
exchange and he goes with 6cm Kansas you
should go see for even those in
particular Knight f3 c6 you can argue
that Bishop d3 is not too bad because of
the development term to SIG's a bit slow
but this is the most interesting way of
doing things so much go back
just normal moves always hoping for
Bishop g4 which is not really great
okay yeah this would give me an this is
this can lead to a disaster for blanket
threatening h4 h5 now and he has to be
extremely alert okay it's not trying
even to defend it just playing a movie
immediately so f4 are you lost then
already on or not it's going to be going
to be difficult and so on
yeah maybe f4 f6 still holes it looks it
looks bad but it might not lose a
mid-level team it could lose a medium
have sex so now take and queen d3 maybe
mmm caretaking is probably best
so quindi three or okay when the bishop
cannot move anyway and the knight cannot
move anyway that's a pretty awkward pin
okay let's go Queen d3 does he have a
move in this one okay
hmmm uncertainly really uncertain what's
the best yet it looks absolutely bad but
how do you how do you kill him
immediately
to keep the night on the board and their
mini moves that looks look very
promising I also like twin g3 let's try
that it's it's tough to say it just just
a good it is such a good position that
you have a hard time to decide what here
what you want to play actually at the
end
hmm checking and queen to d3 is also
going to be strong yeah that's actually
that's very strong
can't shake first
Nate's not going to play g6 okay it's
going to play g6 Wow sofa take him okay
six it's not quite quite winning
[Music]
yeah and down to 18 seconds trying to
try to kill him immediately with
good night before coming I mean that was
so utterly impractical yet in this game
trying to refute this nonsense and then
you get close to losing on time
oh the psychology 87 now Quinn 37 I
guess what do you want coming no no time
absolutely no time I've got Queens III
somehow in this
Queen see how I was the g7 here
maybe Queen I don't know I will take b6
and it's a check Bishop e6 is check
that's really awful I just think is
going to go Queen g7 here or something
like that I'm just an h4 is also going
should be interesting against it and
he's going down with the clock it's
really into good that's good news maybe
Queen f7 this one okay
I don't think you can survive that that
would be amazing
if black is not totally busted him
taking was easier actually but again I
don't see how we can defend it King f8
where's the maid don't see one Queen f5
maybe that was probably doing the trick
he's got no check
probably not doing it in the best
possible way but it's enough yeah it was
I was spending far too much time trying
to win immediately yeah okay so let's
have a look at this a little bit um
Bishop g4 is not a good move simply
because after age three you will be in
some trouble
after g4 all you have to take which is
not what you want this is just super
comfortable for white with a fantastic
bishop so this is very nice and Bishop
h5 leads to concrete problems here you
have to be extremely precise not to lose
a mere name he played that ft5 that is
probably one of the better better
options but now it's really really tough
now Wendy Wendy f6 and I probably didn't
find the absolute refutation so take
take Queen D 323 Queen f3 f3 f3 is
probably stronger
it's just like what do you do him and I
have easy ways to continue to attack
just that bad though
no it's not bad King edge 7 mm f5 was
stronger than Prem's u3 ah this is very
strong I didn't see it okay g5 I can
take this is very very effective of
course like this is a disaster
okay so then that is a lot stronger than
Queen G 3 g5 I checked g6 you know I
should take that bad g8 yeah I'm still
was calling the shots here it it's not
it's not super easy winning Queen you
form and you have spoiled quite a bit of
my advantage
now this is a nice move Queen to g3 it
takes me check this one and night c2
we'll win I guess look at one and that
is a winning attack for white like that
you cannot defend probably the king is
too weak that's plus six or something
okay I went queenie for she took half
takes and this position is indeed not so
clear with me six weeks before 27 was
stronger now I'm in control again it is
winning
I was thinking Queen f7 that was what I
was to create herbs AHA that's simple I
didn't really think about it
yeah then this is why he stopped here
for so long as he saw what I didn't see
that rook the ADA's here of course ha
yeah then you have no defense and you
just have no defend at all
ah he had made it cool sure seen that
one I woke a bishop before it's just
such a disaster I just had a blind spot
here hey Queenie ADA's maid okay it is
winning we named sixes made yeah as I
said I didn't play in the best possible
way but okay winning oops
no winning winning all this material
here it is decisive oh no I'm actually
winning even more stuff here sorry it
moves the king this is the Lukas trapped
okay yes thanks for watching